the stories now have got about that they  play a role in the in the spread of the  disease that's just nonsense dangerous  nonsense as well and I'm hand over to  Steve to say a little bit more about the  vital importance of knocking down this  rubbish yes all right so the five G  story is complete and utter rubbish it's  nonsense it's the worst kind of fake  news the reality is that the mobile  phone networks are absolutely critical  to all of us particularly in a time when  we are asking people to stay at home and  to not see relatives and friends but in  particular those are also the phone  networks that are used by our emergency  services and our health workers and I'm  absolutely outraged absolutely disgusted  that people would be taking action  against the very infrastructure that we  need to respond to this health emergency  it is absolute and utter rubbish and I  can't condemn it in stronger terms than  that